vous savez quels sont les meilleurs
conseils qu'on peut vous donner pour
rester en bonne santé
évitez et la cigarette les nuits courtes
[Musique]
la malbouffe la sédentarité l'isolément
etc
vous voyez où je veux en venir ce sont
exclusivement des conseils négatif ce
sont des choses à ne pas faire
l'idée derrière c'est que quel que soit
le domaine où l'on cherche à s'améliorer
la manière la plus efficace de
progresser c'est d'abord de retirer ce
qui nuit c'est ce qu'on appelle la vie à
négative à c'est une méthode
intellectuels issus de la réflexion de
théologiens du moyen-orient qui ont
trouvé plus facile de décrire dieu en
partant de ce qu'il n'est pas
intéressant et si on appliquait cette
méthode à la dissertation
[Musique]
comment est ce que j'ai trouvé les cinq
pires défauts et bien et j'ai lu et
corrigé beaucoup de copies
principalement des copies de concours
parce que je veux donner à mes élèves
les meilleurs conseils pour les concours
je connais aussi personnellement des
correcteurs donc je sais ce qu'il
déteste dans une dissertation je sais
aussi qu'il ya une chose qu'il valorise
plus que tout en dissertation la
méthodologie
ça tombe bien j'ai ce qu'il vous faut
inscrivez-vous à mon tour gratuit de
méthodologie de la dissertation soit en
cliquant sur le lien qui apparaît
maintenant en haut à droite de la vidéo
soit en cliquant sur celui tiers dans la
description de cette vidéo il ya déjà
plus de 30 mille élèves qui l'ont suivi
donc je sais que vous ne serez pas déçus
mais ne partez pas tout de suite vous
découvrirez mon cours de méthodologie
plus tard regardez attentivement cette
vidéo jusqu'au bout parce qu éviter les
pires défauts et la manière la plus
efficace de progresser en dissertation
évitez donc les cinq défauts que je vais
liste et vous gagnerez plusieurs points
dès votre pré shell dissertation
[Musique]
parfois quand j'ouvre le fichier pdf que
m'a envoyé un de mes élèves je me dis
[ __ ] je n'ai pas lu un seul mot de sa
copie que je suis déjà désespérée elle
est difficile à lire mal aérée donc je
sais j'anticipe que je vais devoir faire
un effort
rien que pour réussir à lire la
dissertation donc une mauvaise
lisibilité et plus généralement une
mauvaise présentation c'est
catastrophique parce que ça crée un
biais de confirmation négatif le
correcteur à un a priori négatif sur
votre dissertation avant même d'en avoir
lu un seul mot en pratique c'est comme
si votre copine était plus notée sur 20
mai sur cèze voir sur 15
vous commencez avec un gros handicap
c'est comme si vous vous rendiez à un
entretien selon vous être lavés depuis
plusieurs jours et avec des habits sales
même si vous êtes charismatique ça va
être compliqué de séduire le jury
donc si vous voulez éviter de partir
avec un handicap
soignez la présentation de votre copie
penser aux correcteurs et écrivez bien
lisiblement éviter les ratures
subdiviser votre rédaction en
paragraphes et aérez votre dissertation
d'accord a les défauts numéro 2 parfois
je lis la copie d'un de mes élèves et je
me dis ça ferait une bonne fiche de
course je la garderai bien cette copie
mais c'est mauvais signe parce qu'une
dissertation ne doit pas ressembler à
une fiche de court le deuxième pire
défaut en dissertation c'est donc de
réciter son cours c'est catastrophique
parce que ça révèle que vous n'avez pas
compris ce qu'est l'exercice de la
dissertation
je vous répète ce que j'ai dit dans pas
mal de vidéos la dissertation n'est pas
un contrôle de connaissances
c'est un exercice de réflexion et
d'expression écrite pour bien comprendre
les enjeux des dissertations aller voir
ma vidéo intitulée qu'est ce qu'une
dissertation pour la trouverez
facilement sur cette chaîne youtube
alors qu'est ce que vous devez faire
pour éviter ce défaut c'est une question
de priorisation ne pensez pas
explicitement à partir de vos
connaissances mais donner la priorité
aux arguments aux idées qui permettent
de répondre aux problèmes internes
elle de la dissertation il connaissances
doivent venir en dernier pour
crédibiliser vos éléments de réponse
c'est tout pour ce deuxième défaut on
passe au suivant ce défaut vous le
connaissez bien c'est un peu votre
hantise en dissertation
c'est le hors sujet pourquoi est-ce que
c'est grave
le hors sujet et bien parce que ça veut
dire que vous ne traitez pas le sujet
comme vous a donné vous visez à côté
alors certes quand vous commettez un
hors sujet vous ne déballe et pas à
votre cour vous avez compris que vous
devez réfléchir mais vous réfléchissez
mal pour le dire plus précisément il
vous manque la qualité la plus
importante de la réflexion la pertinence
et encore une fois c'est grave parce que
la pertinence c'est la qualité qui
garantit l'efficacité de la
communication humaine c'est la
pertinence qui garantit la bonne
circulation de l'information dans la
société
si je vous demande leur vous n'allez pas
me répondre il fait 12 degrés et à c'est
pareil en dissertation une question vous
est posée c'est votre problématique
alors répondez le plus précisément
possible à cette question comment faire
en pratique je vous dit quoi faire dans
la vidéo qui s'intitule 3 astuces pour
éviter le hors sujet vous la trouverez
facilement sur cette chaîne youtube mais
ne la regardais pas maintenant parce que
vous devez à tout prix éviter les deux
derniers défauts je me souviens bien il
y a deux ans je suis resté bloqué en
lisant enfin essayant de lire une
annonce de plan c'était la première
copie que m'avait donné à corriger un de
mes élèves je relisais et je relisais
encore l' annonce de plan et je me
disais mais c'est pas possible je
comprends rien qu'est ce que j'ai comme
le sujet de la dissertation était sur la
conscience l'élève avait boureille son
plan de jargon philosophique et c'était
incompréhensible
il y avait cherché à m'impressionner
mais il a réussi linverse le quatrième
pire défaut en dissertation c'est donc
l'obscurité du style c'est
catastrophique parce que les correcteurs
valorise linverse la clarté du style il
sur note même les copies qu'ils peuvent
lire facilement
alors qu'est ce que vous pouvez faire
pour éviter de transformer la lecture de
votre copie en un exercice de traduction
dans l'esprit de la ville est négative à
la priorité c'est d'éviter les défauts
de style mon élève lui abusé du jargon
mais vous devez plus généralement évité
d'employer les termes que vous ne
maîtrisez pas parfaitement pour purifier
votre style évitez également les phrases
trop longue les formulations compliqué
ou encore les adverbes et si vous voulez
améliorer votre style en vue de la
dissertation regarder ma vidéo qui
s'intitule les trois secrets pour
améliorer son style vous la trouverez
facilement sur cette chaîne youtube
allez cinquième et dernier défaut
[Musique]
souvent quand je lis vos emails et je
lis tous les emails que je reçois
souvent quand je lis vos emails je
m'arrache les cheveux il ya plusieurs
fautes par phrase quasiment pas de
ponctuation ni d'accent et parfois vous
ne m'étais même pas de majuscule à mon
prénom
alors c'est vrai que certains élèves
écrivent correctement mais ils sont
vraiment une minorité vous fait mauvaise
impression quand vous commettez des
fautes dans un email mais en
dissertation c'est pire parce que c'est
un exercice d expression écrite
si vous vous dites les fautes c'est pas
grave ce qui compte ce sont les idées
si vous vous dites ça vous vous trompez
lourdement vous vous trompez lourdement
parce que les fautes d'expression sont
un défaut probablement pire qu'une
mauvaise présentation le premier des
cinq défauts parce que la correction de
la langue est une chose sacrée pour le
correcteur la langue française c'est son
outil de travail c'est probablement son
obsession et vous vous la négliger vous
vous en servez comme si ce n'avait pas
de valeur
vous risquez donc de créer un biais de
confirmation pire que celui créé par une
mauvaise présentation vous risquez de
vous attirer le mépris du correcteur
j'espère que je vous ai convaincu parce
que si vous faites beaucoup de fautes
ça ne sera pas seulement le correcteur
qui vous méprisent rats mais aussi plus
tard dans votre vie professionnelle
vos supérieurs vos collègues en fait
toutes les personnes auxquelles vous
écrirez alors comment faire moins de
fautes
je vous recommande trois choses la
première c'est de vous surveillez vous
même plus attentivement lorsque vous
écrivez et cela quel que soit le texte
que vous écrivez un petit message ou un
commentaire ce n'est pas une excuse pour
se laisser aller
la deuxième chose à faire c'est de
vérifier systématiquement lorsque vous
avez un doute
en plus aujourd'hui c'est très facile
vous tapez ce que vous voulez vérifier
dans google et vous avez la réponse en
quelques secondes troisième chose à
faire relisez-vous non seulement vous
devez prévoir quelques minutes de
relecture à la fin de l'épreuve de
dissertation
mais vous avez intérêt à vous relire
quel que soit le texte que vous écrivez
vous allez peut-être me trouvais extrême
mais je n'envoie jamais
un email ni même un simple message de
quelques mots sans l'avoir lu au moins
une fois et c'est la raison principale
pour laquelle je fais très peu de fautes
donc corriger les emails que vous
m'écrivez et vous verrez que vous ferez
moins de fautes en dissertation
[Musique]
ça y est vous connaissez les cinq pires
défauts à éviter en dissertation une
présentation copie désagréable le
déballage du court le hors sujet
l'obscurité du style et enfin les fautes
d'expression plutôt que de vous
focaliser sur des détails
évitez à tout prix ces cinq défauts et
vous réaliserez de gros progrès en
dissertation et si vous voulez
progresser encore plus vite
inscrivez-vous à mon cours gratuits de
méthodologie de la dissertation soit en
cliquant sur le lien qui apparaît
maintenant aux audois de les vidéos soit
en cliquant sur celui qui est dans la
description de cette ville puis si vous
voulez mais signalé les défauts de cette
vidéo vous pouvez le faire dans les
commentaires en tout cas j'espère
vraiment qu'elle vous sera utile malgré
ses défauts je suis romain je suis
toujours avec mon fidèle aristote et
vous étiez sur mille idées de culture
générale
rappelez vous que vous n'avez pas besoin
de vous prendre la tête pour progresser
rapidement en dissertation
[Musique]